il pourrait y avoir aux nouveaux iphone
onze nouvelles références qui ont été
déposés près ce bazar alors rassurez
vous pétez pas un plomb tout de suite on
va regarder ça maintenant
bon on se calme on se calme on se calme
je sais que dès qu'on parle de l'iphone
tout de suite c'est tout le monde sait
la passion c'est tout le monde veut sa
bande rappeler ce qui se passe alors
qu'ils coulent aux effectivement
nouvelle référence là pourquoi pas se
mentir mais je vous explique un peu et
on va prendre ça tranquillement sans mal
un jouet explique tout part du site
consomag qui a repéré que l'union
économique eurasienne a autorisé pas
moins de onze nouvelles références de
smartphones qui peuvent être vendus sur
le sol arménien biélorusse et kazakh
kirghizes et russe
onze modèles inconnu au bataillon alors
je ne pense pas qu'on ait 11 nouveaux
iphone qui vont arriver là pour
l'instant ne soit pas l'intérêt pour
apple de sortir onze nouveaux produits
d'un coup mais par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est d'abord d'être
déclinaisons et tous ces produits seront
équipés d'ailleurs et 11 alors dans la
mesure où il s'occupait d'aliose il est
très clair que l'on ne parle pas du tout
des iphone qui seront annoncées au mois
de septembre qui eux seront sous ios 12
eyeos 12 qui va être officialisée ou
d'allemagne où il avait lui dit si en
juin de cette année qui sera en version
bêta durant tout le mois de juillet tout
le mois d'août et qui sortira pour le
grand public au mois de septembre avec
les nouveaux iphone donc si on parle de
onze nouveaux iphone sous ios
11 on parle de produits plutôt low cost
alors je sais low cost si apple c'est
toujours un peu marre et mais ça
pourrait être en tout cas ce qu'on
attend c'est à dire un iphone os de
l'iphone et ce stand produits d'entrée
de gamme le produit coûte moins cher
chez apple un produit qui s'est beaucoup
vendu avec vraiment un petit écran mais
qui a toujours beaucoup de succès alors
ses iphone et ce2 vous en disent déjà
parlé il fait vous couler beaucoup
d'encre et il intéresse beaucoup de
monde est effectivement là ça pourrait
que le cas lorsqu'on imagine sec avec 11
référence il pourrait y avoir des
déclinaisons peut-être des déclinaisons
de couleurs peut-être des déclinaisons
technique en capacité de stockage
bon il ya pas mal de choses à voir là
dessus en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils se passe des choses du côté de
chez apple d'ailleurs sas avait déjà
remarqué
du point de vue de l'ipad il n'y a pas
très longtemps toujours le site consomag
avait remarqué effectivement de
nouvelles références d' ipad l'ipad
cellulaire et l'ipad wifi et peu de
temps après effectivement apple avait
annoncé la sortie de ses ipad alors je
serais surpris qu'ils fassent une
nouvelle qui note avant le débat nous de
venir ici mais après tout pourquoi pas
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que au
début
ici on devrait avoir de belles surprises
pas seulement d'un point de vue logiciel
je pense quoi aussi reparler de duos
mode peut-être d'un ipad pro ça pourrait
être super intéressant mais pourquoi pas
d'un iphone s2 des iphone low cost avec
pourquoi pas un grand écran et pourquoi
pas facile dit ça pour être vraiment
hyper cool alors je sais que pour
l'instant il un petit peu tôt pour
définir un profil de ses produits un
profil technique bien évidemment je
serais surpris par contre qu'apple nous
sorte un iphone est ce identiques aux
produits actuels ça serait une faute de
goût de toute façon le design actuel des
iphone et ce et des iphone 8 7-6 6-7 et
compagnie est vraiment en train de
disparaître au profit du nouveau look et
dessiné par iphone 10 ça sera la même
chose à mon avis pour ses iphone s 2 à
voir maintenant les finitions pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas les iphones et
ce2 un petit peu dans une gamme couleur
comme on arrive dans le cinq c'est avec
différentes teintes ça pour être bien se
donner un petit peu un petit coup de
jeune
ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui que de toute
façon apple doit faire face à la
concurrence de plus en plus forte
samsung bien évidemment ça fait un bon
moment huawei qui frappe fort aussi avec
ses tout nouveaux produits qui sont
vraiment très intéressant au nord qui
appartient toujours à huawei est bien
évidemment tous les autres one plus au
bauchi hobby et tous les autres qui
arrivent en force directement et qui
vont arriver très bientôt tous en france
lâche part effectivement de la france
non va imaginer ça à l'échelle
internationale parce que apple se bat
effectivement à l'échelle internationale
je vous apprends rien là je vous parle
effectivement d'un marché autour de la
russie donc ils ont tout intérêt à
proposer des produits qui sont pas
forcément trop cher d'excellente qualité
est vraiment sexy
d'où en tout cas ces onze prochaine
référence donc dites moi ce que vous en
pensez à votre avis à quoi pourrait
ressembler ces 11 nouveaux iphone ça
sera pas on se produit différent je vous
dis une fois de plus mais onze
déclinaison à voir un peu comment ils
vont être faits sa peine en tout cas
très intéressant
alors dites vous bien que s'il y a un
aux produits qui ont été autorisés en
vendre en russie en biélorussie en
arménie y aura peut-être pas aux
produits autorisés en france mais
peut-être trois couleurs donc trois
références différentes
d'abord après la déclinaison ça peut
être un petit peu une piste de réflexion
donc marquer moi tous vos commentaires
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous avez hâte de voir un nouvel
iphone
arrivé au d'abeilles au dab
d'ici on joint ou alors est ce que vous
pensez a contrario qu'il va falloir
attendre le mois de septembre pour
arriver de nouveaux iphone des iphone
avec des très grands écrans oled
toujours plus sexy toujours plus réussis
toujours plus cool
mark et moi tout ça en commentaire comme
d'hab vous invite à blesser des jolies
pousse à vous abonner vous allez voir on
va parler ça de très près c'est un sujet
qui est hyper passionnant d'ici là
portez vous bien soyez sages j'ai hâte
de lire tous vos commentaires et puis à
très bientôt
[Musique]